okay guys we have to start today with
a very real very sobering conversation
i wish we didn't have to have this
conversation but i'm not going to blow
smoke up down in out of anywhere
um maybe we can get something positive
out of it and i don't say that in a sort
of
coy or you know kind of bs way a
teachable moment like maybe we can
actually get something out of this
because it's increasingly clear that
republicans if they choose to if they
decide
that the political risks are reasonable
are going to have the votes to move
forward
with a replacement of ruth bader
ginsburg on the supreme court
yes they are hypocrites yes they're
completely ignoring the guidelines
they claimed were necessary in 2016
to deny barack obama a supreme court
pick
to replace the late justice antonin
scalia with merrick garland
but the reality is we have to deal with
reality that democrats right now
don't have a path to stopping donald
trump
from replacing ruth bader ginsburg it
will be up to republicans
remember that the numbers are
republicans of 53 of the 100 senate
seats
in order to deny them the 51 or it's
really
50 votes that they have to be denied
because even in a 50 50 vote mike pence
gets to tie break and you know how that
will go
we need to find four republicans who
will refuse to move forward with a
confirmation
we heard from lisa murkowski from alaska
she is one such republican who has said
at least not before the election during
the lame duck
who knows we then heard from susan
collins from maine
another republican senator who says not
before the election
no but bear in mind even
if we wait it out until november 3rd and
joe biden wins
these same two republicans lisa
murkowski and susan collins
may well be willing to push someone
through during a lame duck period
and in any case two isn't going to be
enough to stop it uh donald tru
uh mitt romney rather is someone that
people have been looking towards maybe
mitt romney could be a third republican
as of right now mitt romney has said
uh it looks like he's going to be okay
moving forward and
even if mitt romney could be added as
number three to the list you need a
fourth
so the reality today is
we have to contend with this
situation there is a very real practical
lesson here
and it's a lesson to all of those people
you remember them i remember them some
of them even have youtube channels
who in 2016 were saying trump and
hillary
are two sides of the same coin
if it's trump or hillary i don't care
they're both corporatist centrists and
it really doesn't matter which one is
elected for the next four years or eight
years
and i mentioned the supreme court in
2015 and 2016 and
you know some of these clowns some of
them said supreme court
it's not like hillary's going to pick
any real left wingers to the court
well donald trump stole one from obama
with neil gorsuch
and then he got brett kavanaugh two
ludicrous ideologues the likes of which
hillary clinton
never would have even considered putting
on the court
and now donald trump is on the verge of
ingraining the most conservative supreme
court in a long time
by replacing ruth bader ginsburg with a
straight up
handmaid's tale right wing cultist
who i will be talking about later this
is not
i told you so stuff this is a learning
experience
this is learning from mistakes if we can
learn from it now if we can't
then we arguably deserve what's coming
and what's coming could be very very bad
the supreme court did matter the people
who wrote it off
in 2016 and the people who are writing
it off right now
in 2020 they were wrong they are wrong
period abortion rights are now going to
be in question
partially because there were people in
2016 who mistakenly thought
trump or hillary is going to lead to the
same results this is not about shaming
people
this is not about shame this is about
hey guys
some of us questioned the importance of
the difference between trump and hillary
in 2016 not me but some of us did
this is about understanding that there
are things we can control
and things we can't control in 2016 we
could control
our votes in the primaries once hillary
was the nominee
we couldn't change that but we could
then control
whether we voted in november of 2016 and
who we voted for and some people made
the decision not to vote
some people who supported candidates
other than hillary during the primary
made the decision not to vote or to vote
for trump or to write somebody in or
whatever
and of course a whole bunch of other
things happened as well which affected
the results but it was ultimately 77 000
votes in three key states
and now donald trump is going to get his
third supreme court pick
in one term possibly with more coming if
he gets a second term
they were wrong then many of them acted
like
spoiled children then they're not the
only thing to blame
of course but they were wrong the whole
both sides are the same ideology
is an easy way for
lazy people or intellectually uncurious
people
to feel as though they're above it all
i've sometimes used the term enlightened
centrist there's also these folks on the
left and on the right it's not just
centrists
and it has been a disaster so okay it's
almost october what can we control now
we can control whether we vote in this
election
we can control whether donald trump gets
four more years
and potentially one or even two
more supreme court picks and as a result
gets to set the country on what will
potentially be
one of its darkest periods certainly of
the 21st century but probably for
for longer and if you need any further
words of warning
let's discuss next who donald trump is
considering
to replace ruth bader ginsburg
it's dystopian let's discuss it
real quick i want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon
who have done something awesome they've
taken all of our favorite sugary
childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar free
gluten free grain free soy free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman's show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n